I have like a tiny little scar so I
blacked out one time and I don't
remember what happened like uh uh yeah I
think I told the story on the podcast no
I don't think so so I went we had this
game I I swear I've told the story we
had this game where you'd have like four
cups like this like four like if you
imagine like orange juice glasses yeah
like this you'd line them up one two
three four uh and then if you can
imagine there's like a little there'd be
a little Gap in the middle right so
you'd all take it in turns flicking
coins in which now is also just a dirty
thought to think that we're putting
coins in our drinks so if you have to
flick coins in they'd all have a shot of
vodka each in them oh uh and you'd also
you did before of you sitting uh on each
side of the table yeah and so you would
flick a coin in and if you've got it in
one and then Joey you also didn't get it
in you would have to drink it with the
coins inside of it uh well you would
drink the coin you'd take you can't
drink it and then get the coin out yeah
yeah I know I know I know you're a
[__] Universe yeah of course of
course
um and I I these are people who I just
moved in with and I really wanted to be
accepted by them so I was like yeah
so what ended up happening was that if
you if you get it in uh the another
glass as well the next person if they
don't get it M1 has to do two oh [__]
and I can keep going but there's another
thing where if you get it in between all
of them uh you have to do all of them oh
like a little Gap yeah if someone
doesn't then and so I had that and I had
to drink all four of them all these
shots which were very generous shots
yeah the vodka and I was like oh God
okay then I lost again in the middle
because I ended up doing like like 10
shots it's four but they were definitely
big yeah yeah the ridiculous amount of
shots back to back and then everyone's
like yeah let's go up to the club now
and then I just do not remember but
apparently I went
and then I woke up the next day I was
like [__] my head hurts then I woke up
and there's just blood on my wall and
blood all over my room what blood all
over my bed and then I look in the
mirror and my like my eyes completely
swollen over yeah so I must have just
[__] face planted at some point yeah
on the ground and hit concrete uh cut
open my my uh but my head there she's
very lucky that it was just like there
right here not my eye yeah uh yeah and
then I got trying a little scar now you
can't see it uh but yeah so that was the
first time and uh hopefully it'll last
yeah it's uh it's yeah I think I like a
similar
instance in University there's nothing
more terrifying the pressures are very
powerful thing it is it is it is a very
powerful thing uh which we can say now
as adults uh [__] overrated you guys
are better than that yeah
um to me there's nothing more terrifying
than opening my eyes and just not
recognizing my immediate surrounding
yeah oh yeah I've been there yeah yeah
you know it's funny like even even if
you like even if I sleep over at a
friend's place I I I miss my bed too
much yeah and I I hate I always dread
the feeling of like waking up and I'm
just like where the [__] am I yeah no
matter how drunk I am I'm using 100 of
my remaining brain power to be like I'm
gonna make it back to this bed
like no matter what like I I I could be
so I could be like just incoherent like
you can't even like understand what I'm
saying but in my head I'm just like bed
now I'll get there I I've had moments in
my life where I have uh barely been you
know conscious drunk you know that kind
of like [__] stupid ass drunk and
somehow there is one part of my brain
that is like a [__] uh messenger
pigeon like it it has like built-in GPS
to like be able to walk me home no
matter where I am and I'm just like how
the [__] can I do this yeah you know
it's not my story but my favorite
blackout story is from one of my friends
in Japan uh he was out drinking in like
shibio Shinjuku or somewhere like few
years ago and like just got absolutely
like destroyed like he was like so drunk
but he somehow he was lit it was he was
drinking kind of close to where he was
living right yeah in this apartment so
he's like okay well I'm not gonna have a
problem like walking home like I know
where I am uh but the problem was that
because it's an apartment you know all
the doors look the same all right so
what so what he thought was his own
house that he walked into uh turned out
to be the exact same like room number
but on the floor below oh [__] and and
at the time he thought he was like oh
it's really weird that this door is just
like open like did I just like forget to
unlock this door because it does like no
key was involved like he just opened the
door right oh and he only found out that
he was in the wrong apartment because he
woke up and you know like just on the
floor of of this apartment that he
thought was his and he just looked over
and basically where you were sitting
where you're sitting right now got there
was just like a pig
[Laughter]
because apparently the neighbor
downstairs in secret was owning this pet
pig that's some [__] hangover yeah
lock his door if he has an illegal Pig
in there yeah and then apparently like
he was like he just looked over he saw
this pig and he was like oh God I'm in
the wrong apartment and then right on
cue the owner of that apartment came out
of his bedroom and he was like the [__]
are you doing well good thing he's uh he
wasn't in America oh my God imagine I
had a friend one time and told me about
uh he got really drunk uh and when he
was walking home and like I guess he
just fell asleep walking home yeah and
uh apparently he woke up and he was in a
building and they were housing like
refugees in the building and the
refugees saw him on the ground and like
brought him in and like shed their like
floor space holy [__] and he was like
what the [__] woke up and he and
apparently he added them on Facebook and
they like keep in touch sometimes still
because they were super chill about it
they were like very helpful that's so
funny uh but that must have been a
bizarre a bizarre experience he just
woke up and you're surrounded by Ricky
she's like trying to help you yeah
you're like what the heck where am I God
that's a [__] wild story I'm sure he
could tell the story much better he told
me that in full detail but that was the
only part I really remember it sounded
like [__] insane it was like what
yeah yeah I mean [__] you know I'm
glad I'm glad we're not that stupid
anymore hopefully hopefully well that's
that's part of being an adult you know
you get older you get smarter you don't
do that stuff anymore yeah and you
realize it's not worth it yeah yeah well
it's just you realize it's not that fun
you also like fun is so relative and for
some reason people think that's cool and
fun to do and you're like actually it's
kind of [__] boring sure yeah I mean
I think I've realized I think when I
realized that hangovers actually
affected me for like more than one day
was was when I [__] you know what I mean
you know what I mean they hang over
could you when was the last time you
guys stayed up all night
where do we stay up all night stayed up
all night 24 hour 24 hours in ages yeah
yeah because even the thing I couldn't
do at all show do you remember back in
the day when it was like you just got
really into a video game and it was
really easy
when I discovered Terraria it's just so
many nights I would never just stay up
24 hours I would always go to bed at
some point even if it was like one hour
really I really couldn't do it yeah oh I
I did it so many times when I was in uni
yeah it was just a six and I was like
well
she got at least two hours in well
sometimes you just need like one more
League game and it's just like one more
League games I want to end on a win and
then you're like [__] seven wins but
then you end on a win and then you're
like actually I gotta complain until I
lose
yeah yeah yeah exactly no I mean like I
I can still like stay up all night it's
really weird because there's something
in my brain that just allows me to like
stay up as late as I want but as soon as
I go to bed like it I I pay the I pay
like the tax you know that's why I'm
always like the last one up but you will
never see me the next day because I am
like unfunctional I think that's my
problem is that like now I've done it
enough times and I know the limits of my
own body and mind we're like fully
respectable yeah if I if I think to
myself okay it's like already three in
the morning uh which is already past my
bedtime yeah I could just stay up like I
I physically would be able to do it but
at what cost yeah you know and when I
think about that I'm like the cost is
not worth it I'd rather just go to bed
yeah yeah I like sleeping too much so we
talked about